this is how the DJI mic 2 sounds like
and boy is it refreshing to hear my
voice on something else other than our
reliable gold Wireless goto microphones
that we used for most if not all of our
videos but now it's time for an upgrade
not only does this sound good but it
looks fantastic too especially since you
can use this magnet that's included on
the clips to hide your mics You've Got 5
and 1 half hours of battery life on the
transmitters and up to 15 hours with the
case with 14 hours of compressionless 48
khz 24-bit audio because of its 8
internal storage you've got a Nifty 0.96
in OLED screen to adjust and monitor
everything to do with the mics and with
a range of 250 M you can go pretty far
oh my
god wow it comes with a whole bunch of
accessories to connect these to your
phone as well you got a pouch mic wind
screen and so much more it's time to up
your audio game with the DJI mic 2